vous venez donc devoir les deux premiers
épisodes de notre série exclusive V13
réalisée par les journalistes Vincent
Nouzille et Théo Ivanez et ce au moment
où la cour des 6 spéciale chargée du
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
vient de rendre voilà quelques jours
sont verdict avant de vous proposer les
trois autres volets de cette série avec
nos invités présents maintenant sur ce
plateau de débat doc nous allons revenir
sur ce qui ont été les temps forts de ce
procès et sur son dénouement Vincent
nouzi tout d'abord est avec nous sur ce
plateau bienvenue vous êtes donc le
co-auteur je l'ai dit de ce film au côté
de Théo Ivanez vous êtes journaliste
d'investigation auteur de nombreux
livres d'enquêtes historico politique de
documentaire et on va préciser d'emblée
que vous avez tourné
un nouveau film une nouvelle série
peut-être autour cette fois du procès
cette série là a été tournée juste avant
ce fameux procès auquel vous avez
assisté évidemment et vous êtes en le
tournage pour débriefer ce qui a été le
verdict ce que nous allons faire ici
aussi dans quelques instants avec Claire
je serai Schmidt bienvenue vous étiez
avocat de 37 parties civiles à ce procès
des attentats du 13 novembre et vous
avez la réputation aussi je l'ai eu
quelque part d'être celle qui est
parvenue à faire parler salam teslaam on
en dira bien sûr un mot tout à l'heure
Mathieu Delahousse est également avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes journaliste au
magazine l'Obs dont vous dirigez la
cellule investigation vous êtes un
spécialiste des affaires judiciaires et
auteurs entre autres de ce livre le prix
de nos larmes c'est un document qui
dévoile les dessous de l'indemnisation
des victimes d'attentats terroristes et
pas seulement bien sûr des victimes de
cette journée du 13 novembre c'est un
livre publié aux éditions de
l'Observatoire et puis on fait avec nous
Rafael Kampf bienvenue vous êtes avocat
pénaliste au barreau de Paris avocat de
la défense lors de ce procès où vous
avez ou défendiez Yacine Attar qui n'est
autre que le frère d'Oussama
des responsables de la branche
renseignement du groupe état islamique
celui qui selon les magistrats français
à commandité les attentats parisiens
depuis RACA en Syrie ce dernier faisait
lui aussi d'ailleurs un parti des
accusés de ce procès mais était non
présent dans le box des accusés puisque
présumé mort à la suite d'une frappe
aérienne occidentale en zone Irako
syrienne c'était en novembre 2017 votre
client a été condamné à huit ans
d'emprisonnement avec deux tiers de
période de sûreté on notera que c'est
moins que ce qui avait été recu requis
pardon par le ministère public c'est
peut-être un succès pour vous en en
parlera tout tout à l'heure à l'issue de
ce verdict concernant votre votre client
première question on l'a dit redit et
c'est bien stipulé bien sûr dans votre
série Vincent nous y on s'attendait à un
procès historique ça a été le cas
presque 10 mois de débat et à chacun
d'entre vous je vais commencer tout
simplement par vous demander ce qui a
été le moment fort à que de ces presque
10 mois de débat de ce fameux procès du
13 novembre 2015 dans ce procès
historique il y a eu énormément de
moments forts mais moi j'en retiens un
qui m'a particulièrement touché
à la fois parce que c'est une victime
partie civile Nadia moneyer qui est la
mère de Lamia Lamia a été tuée à la
belle équipe le soir du 13 novembre et
Nadia monégier est de notre film nous
avons décidé de la de la suivre toujours
pour le film que nous faisons sur le
procès lui-même et elle est venue à la
barre un jour en octobre au milieu de
centaines de participants du témoignés
c'est au début du procès qui a commencé
en septembre et elle est venue le début
octobre et elle l'a dit des mots
notamment sur ses accusés qui auraient
pu avoir le même âge
qui avait le même âge que sa fille
décédée et ses propos ont résonné assez
fort et ils ont raisonné quatre mois
plus tard lorsque l'un des accusés qui
s'appelle Sofiane yari considéré comme
un combattant aguerri de l'État
islamique parti en Syrie qui était
présumé peut-être faire un attentat à ce
qui Paul autour du 13 novembre ce
jour-là il s'est levé lui il était
interrogé sur sa radicalisation et il a
dit aujourd'hui je parle parce que cette
femme m'a émue elle aurait pu être ma
mère
et je lui dois une explication et ce
jour là on s'est dit d'une part Nadia
mon des guerres était dans la salle et
elle a compris que les mots qu'elle
avait dit à la barre avait un sens
qu'ils avaient peut-être été entendu par
les accusés et dans le fond peut-être
c'est ça le message principal d'un
procès c'est qui se passe des choses
c'est que la parole des uns rencontre la
parole des autres ça ne veut pas dire
que la sincérité des uns ne peut pas
être mise en question notamment celle
des accusés mais c'est la rencontre
c'est une confrontation mais c'est aussi
un dialogue qui est possible et c'est ce
qui s'est passé
lors de ce témoignage de neymonegger et
lors de cette réponse de Sofiane hayari
4-4 mois plus tard pour moi c'est le
moment fort parce qu'il symbolise il
incarne il révèle des moments possibles
qu'une audience permet
397 victimes proches de ces victimes ont
témoigné à l'occasion de ce procès
est-ce que c'est un de ces témoignages
qui vous av aussi marqué ou est-ce que
vous dégagez d'emblée un autre moment
fort de ce procès il y a beaucoup de
temps forts dans ce procès Vincent nous
y vient de rappeler un qui compte
beaucoup pour moi aussi qui restera
beaucoup dans ma mémoire je vais vous en
citer un autre mais il y en a d'autres
pendant le procès et même en marge du
procès parce qu'il y a eu les après pro
les suspensions au cours du décès il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses je vais
vous parler du témoignage de d'Alain
Valette qui est le père de Guillaume
belette c'est un jeune homme qui a
survécu au Bataclan qui n'a pas été
blessé dans sa chair mais qui a éprouvé
ce que l'on appelle des blessures
invisibles ces blessures psychiques qui
ne se voit pas ce sont des blessures qui
ont raison de lui il a mis fin à ses
jours deux ans après c'est pendu dans
une clinique et son père est venu parler
de ses balles psychiques qui ont tué son
fils son fils a été traqué par les
terroristes qui n'ont pas réussi à le
tuer dans la nuit du 13 au 14 novembre
mais ils sont parvenus deux ans après
témoignages est très important très fort
parce qu'il dit tout il dit tout de
l'importance de ses blessures que l'on
sous-estime nombre de victimes ont
entendu et je crois que Mathieu vous
pouvez le confirmer on entendu mais tu
n'as pas été blessé tout va bien ça va
mieux maintenant il faut aller de
l'avant les blessures qui ne se voient
pas peuvent handicaper tout autant que
des blessures qui atteignent dans la
chair voilà on rappelle que le bilan
officiel est aide de 130 morts et 350
blessés et ce que vous nous dites là
c'est finalement ce bilan est bien plus
important c'est une personne dont vous
parlez est une des victimes oui le
président de la cour d'assise a évoqué
tout au long du procès 131 victimes en
comptant Guillaume Valette et en
apprenant quelques il y a quelques
semaines qu'une deuxième personne avait
mis fin à ces jours donc on a entendu
parler de 132 victimes Mathieu
Delahousse le moment fort de ce procès à
vos yeux
je pense qu'on en a tous des caisses de
ces moments forts avec beaucoup
d'émotions aussi beaucoup d'explications
de la part de témoins y compris des
policiers qui sont venus mais on a
beaucoup parlé des victimes et c'est
bien normal à cette question moi
j'aurais répondu par le moment où grâce
à une femme qui est une épouse d'un
homme qui est mort au Bataclan
personnellement moi j'ai compris que ce
procès allait porter au-delà de la
petite boîte rectangulaire dans laquelle
il se déroulait cette femme elle
s'appelle Aurélie son mari son compagnon
est mort au Bataclan elle est venue
déposer au début elle voulait pas
assister au procès c'était quand même je
voudrais pas qu'on soit dans une
caricature d'une Concorde complète d'un
procès qui se soit transformé en fait ce
procès n'était était un moment de
douleur à un moment de difficulté et un
moment de questions sans réponse et
cette femme est venue pour la première
fois témoigner puis elle est restée
jusqu'au bout on l'a vu sur les bancs
tout le temps et elle a eu cette
réflexion président perriès elle lui a
dit vous savez j'en ai parlé à mes amis
et l'une de mes amis a fini par me dire
le procès c'est le pays où on voudrait
vivre et c'est une phrase incroyable
mais qui après 148 jours d'audience
résume tellement ça parce que on était
dans une violence incompréhensible des
auteurs morts donc des accusés qui
étaient là mais les auteurs principaux
n'étaient pas là et c'est un procès où
on a eu des réponses à énormément de
questions et c'est le pays où on
voudrait vivre c'est évidemment un
procès avec des explications un procès
avec des gens qui écoutent et qui
apportent des choses et puis une forme
de climat si l'on peut dire qui
contraste beaucoup avec l'autre grand
procès qui s'est déroulé auparavant qui
c'est celui de Charlie Hebdo Charlie
Hebdo l'audience se déroule elle est
très dure c'est l'une des premières et à
l'extérieur il y a le bruit des armes il
y a le bruit des armes il y a une
attaque rue Nicolas Appert il y a une
attaque à Notre-Dame de Nice et il y a
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty l'audience
était marquée par ce bruit extérieur là
dans cette petite boîte je pense que ça
s'est ouvert effectivement c'est
peut-être le pays où on voulait vivre où
on voudrait vivre en tout cas une forme
de paix et une forme de justice
des temps forts évidemment il y en a eu
à foison comme tous j'ai été
particulièrement touché par les
témoignages des partis civils qui ont
déposé à cette barre et je pense que je
ne m'attendais pas moi personnellement à
être transporté et bouleversé de cette
manière là par des parties civils
auxquels j'aurais pu ou auquel j'ai pu
d'ailleurs m'identifier parce que je
suis parisien je suis de cette
génération là je j'ai grandi et j'habite
dans le dans l'est parisien donc oui
évidemment ces moments-là étaient très
fort mais justement la question que je
voulais vous poser en tant qu'avocat de
la défense et vous venez d'y répondre
vous avez été particulièrement ému
évidemment par les témoignages à
participer tout en défendant un des
accusés justement et donc c'est là aussi
un moment donné que je dois reprendre ma
casquette d'avocat de la défense dans ce
dans ce dossier et rappeler qu'un procès
d'assis c'est aussi un procès où on est
en train de juger des personnes qui sont
présumées innocentes et qu'on est en
train d'examiner s'il existe ou pas
contre ces personnes des charges
suffisantes pour pour les condamner il
faut savoir faut le dire au
téléspectateurs qui ne vont peut-être
pas toujours dans des salles de procédés
ne pas trop comment ça se passe que les
procédés sont fondés sur ce qu'on
appelle le principe de l'oralité des
débats c'est-à-dire que tout doit être
discuté par par oral et c'est peut-être
ce qui explique aussi ce que Vincent
nouzil expliqué tout à l'heure sur ce
dialogue possible entre entre des
protagonistes du dossier mais cette
oralité du débat implique que les
policiers qui ont fait l'enquête
viennent à la barre et déposent et
disent comment ils ont enquêté et
comment ils pensent que les personnes
qui sont accusées l'ont été et l'un des
moments très forts pour moi c'est
lorsque les policiers qui ont fait
l'enquête qui dort sont des policiers
belges parce que c'est pour l'essentiel
une enquête belge c'est policiers qui
dont chacun et chacune a pu se rendre
compte à quel point leur enquête était
très souvent lacunaire problématique
insuffisante
caricaturale et c'est vrai que l'un de
ces policiers sur questions que nous lui
avons posé avec mon confrères Christian
Saint-Palais ou nous lui avons posé une
question très simple nous on lui avons
demandé parce que nous défendons Yacine
Attar qui qui dit être innocent de ces
faits là donc c'est l'enjeu est
d'importance toujours proclam son
innocence et qui continuent à le faire
donc nous demandons à cette enquêteur
belge il était peut-être 19 20h 21h en
audience l'audience ça va durer
longtemps nous lui demandons est-ce que
votre enquête a permis de démontrer
d'établir une aide quelconque apportée
par mon client yassinata a la cellule
terroriste et sa réponse a été non
cette enquête notre enquête n'a pas
permis de démontrer cette aide là donc
oui évidemment pour nous avocat de la
défense c'est un moment extrêmement fort
parce que l'une des personnes qui a fait
cette enquête vient dire finalement on
sait pas ce que votre client a fait donc
pour nous on sait dit à ce moment-là on
va vers la voie de l'acquittement on
attendait des réponses de ce procès vous
en avez eu visiblement Matthieu
Delahousse on va parler maintenant des
réponses qui étaient venons attendues
sur ce qu'on a appelé les zones d'ombre
que vous révélez d'ailleurs notamment
dans le documentaire qui va suivre à
notre notre débat qui s'appelle
l'enquête un certain nombre de zones
dont existaient avant la tenue de ce
procès est-ce que ce procès a permis de
les éclairer ces zones d'ombre et là on
est bien sur sur l'enquête évidemment
alors sur les faits notamment des
services de renseignement en amont avant
les attentats ce qu'on raconte dans le
premier épisode
c'est évident que le procès a les a mis
à jour il en a même rajouté parce qu'on
l'a redécouvert un salon de fées
concernant notamment la police belge sur
le fait par exemple les deux frères
Abdeslam salam Islam dans le box Brahim
son frère qui s'est fait offrir aîné son
frère aîné qui s'est fait sauter au
comptoir Voltaire ils avaient été
arrêtés interpellé en février 2015 et le
téléphone de Brahim n'a pas été exploité
par la police belge il a été exploité
qu'après le 13 novembre et si on avait
si il y a la règle des signes on peut
refaire évidemment beaucoup de choses
mais s'il avait exploité dès le mois de
février mars on avait des liens avec
about le l'homme qui était en série on
avait des liens il y avait ces prémices
d'un projet terroriste peut-être que si
la police belge avait fait son travail
correctement à ce moment là
on aurait pu peut-être éviter cette
attaque donc tout ça a été exposé
pendant pendant l'audience ce n'était
pas le procès des services de
renseignement c'était le procès des
accusés le président d'ailleurs a
parfois tenté de recadrer les débats ou
à salon d'accuser par exemple on dit
nous avons fait ces attentats parce que
c'était une représailles par rapport au
bombardement de la coalition en Syrie en
direct ces éléments ont été recadrés par
les débats donc l'audience a permis de
faire avancer un salon de dossier on a
soldé par exemple la polémique sur le
fait de savoir si la Berry était
intervenue assez tôt le soir du 13
novembre pour pour mener l'assaut il y a
eu une polémique avant de procès ce
débat n'a plus lieu d'être aujourd'hui
et elle avait été entretenue d'ailleurs
par la commission d'enquête
parlementaire cette polémique donc cette
tenue ici elle se débat de ce point de
vue là était riche parce qu'il a permis
de répondre à un certain nombre de
questions mais ils en reste beaucoup qui
sont restés ouvertes notamment sur le
rôle de chacun
[Musique]
gilet mais quand on est victime du
Bataclan le gilet ça a certes un intérêt
sur l'enquête mais on avait des gens
dans la salle qui était à deux rangs de
nous et qui quand il y avait sur les
écrans la carte du Bataclan qui
apparaissait disait ah mais moi j'étais
là j'étais à tel endroit j'ai vu cet
homme il y a des gens qui se croisaient
à la machine à café et qui disait mais
c'est vous que j'ai vu dans le bus des
secouristes et donc ce travail de fait
accessoire durant les débats non ça
c'était le premier volet et je pense que
ça n'a pas justement occulté le deuxième
volet qui était sur l'enquête ou j'ai
trouvé de façon remarquable contestable
par la défense qui a fait son rôle mais
remarquable malgré tout les exposés
notamment de la sous-direction de de la
sous-direction antiterroriste pardon de
la police judiciaire ou alors de la DGSI
qui mettait en avant toute cette
dynamique le terrorisme ne vient pas de
nulle part on ne jugeait pas le
terrorisme jugé des hommes mais on
voyait bien aussi qu'on jugeait toute
une partie d'une évolution historique
donc c'est Swan là elles ont été
en avance
le côté belge le côté français les
renseignements français et les
renseignements belges et pas seulement
d'ailleurs
c'est carence ont été mis en avant
malgré tout elles ont été mises en avant
dans votre film elles ont été j'imagine
largement mise en avant durant ce procès
ou pas elle déclare si on a tous les
étages on se rappelle pas que certaines
personnes ont cherché pendant trois
jours quasiment leur mort que certains
une victime ont été interverties avec
d'autres les responsables de l'institut
médico-légal ont dû s'en expliquer le
l'ancien procureur de Paris François
Valens quand il est venu il a dû
s'expliquer là-dessus et ça c'est sur le
côté victime mais sur le côté des
charges qui poursuivaient les hommes qui
étaient dans le box évidemment tout ça
est exploité par la défense avec un vice
d'origine dont on n'a pas parlé mais qui
est que les auteurs sont morts les gens
qui étaient qui ont tenu la kalachnikov
au Bataclan face à la salle en leur
parlant ne sont pas là ils ont décidé de
d'aller devant les policiers pour se
faire pour se faire tuer et du coup
toutes les carences qui concernaient
ceux qui ont été rattrapés ensuite
parfois très tardivement parfois avec
des éléments très ténus tout ça ça a été
ça a été exploré et je pense qu'on a
pris conscience lors de l'audience de la
finesse de certaines accusations pour
par dire l'inexistence de charge du côté
des victimes du côté des victimes on a
entendu près de 400 témoignages de
victimes et pour l'avocate de partie
civile que je suis c'était une très
bonne chose cette oralité des débats
parce que je pense que jamais on a
touché d'aussi près on a mesuré autant
l'importance des blessures et de la
temporalité de ces séquelles dans le
temps pour les personnes que vous
représentiez et pour rejoindre ce qui
vient de dire tout à l'heure
[Musique]
ils ont appris des choses ça leur a
permis de d'avancer dans leur
effet propre
qui a beaucoup beaucoup d'attentes de la
part des procès
il y a beaucoup d'attente et dans le
même temps ils savent beaucoup de choses
sur ces attentats quand même une enquête
assez incroyable qui a été menée pendant
plusieurs années donc on connaît
l'ossature des attentats on n'en sait
pas toujours autant pour tous les
attentats moi j'ai une trentaine de
dossiers d'attentats au cabinet
notamment des attentats à l'étranger
dont on ne se souvient en guerre du
reste on n'en sait pas toujours autant
c'est très difficile d'arriver à la
manifestation de la vérité et là il y a
quand même une ossature notamment grâce
à cette ordinateur qu'on retrouve rue
max rose qui présente quatre mois après
les attentats de Paris une découverte
totalement
improbablement on trouve cet
arborescence qui permet faire connaître
les cibles et l'organisation globale
après oui il y a eu à l'issue des débats
et notamment de la section sur les faits
que j'ai un peu trop courte une certaine
frustration parce que les victimes
attendaient davantage plus que ce que
l'enquête a révélé et sur ce point c'est
un contextable les victimes ont été
enfin beaucoup de victimes je suis
toujours attention de pas dire lait
beaucoup de victimes ont été déçues par
l'absence d'exhaustivité des prises de
parole on a eu le sentiment que les
certains accusés disposaient
d'informations mais ne les livrez pas
spontanément pour quelle raison
exactement bon est-ce que c'est parce
qu'ils ne se sentait pas suffisamment
écoutés ce qui parce qu'ils ont ici ils
n'avaient pas suffisamment de temps et
ce qu'ils ont voulu se protéger les uns
les autres concrètement concrètement moi
mes clients que si vous voulez savoir ok
il y a l'arborescence mais
il arrive quand à quelle date il
rencontre qui Abdeslam à quelle date il
le rencontre quels sont les échanges
comment se passent ces rencontres
comment se décide va se décider le rôle
de chacun le soir du 13 novembre il y a
un jeu de chaise musicale le 12 au soir
à Brignais repart pendant ce briefing
s'enfuit finalement Abdeslam nous dit
bon j'étais pas prévu longtemps à
l'avance mais il est prévu ce soir là il
voulait des détails c'est très important
c'est à dire que ce que Vincent de vie
disait tout à l'heure cette prise de
parole derrière de Sofiane qui dure pas
longtemps c'est une petite connexion un
petit instant d'authenticité que les
victimes ont pris elles sont saisies
elles auraient souhaité davantage de
connexion de ce type là pas forcément
beaucoup mais davantage il leur faut
faire le deuil de tout savoir et ça
c'est pas facile vous souhaitez rajouter
quelque chose et puis je bizarrement je
vous donne la parole tout de suite
Raphaël il faut dire aussi qu'il y a eu
un peu de silence un peu d'omerta dans
le box
il y a quand on l'observe bien au fil
des mois une espèce de hiérarchie
d'ambiance qui se crée dans ce box entre
ces 11 accusés qui étaient dans le box
les trois qui est comparaissaient libres
parce qu'il se parle
et c'est pas tellement autorisé mais il
se parle il y a des il y a des tensions
il y a des rapports certains se
retrouvent depuis 6 ans qui sont à
l'isolement et il y en a certains qui
reprochaient notamment à salade d'eslave
de les avoir embarqués dans cette
histoire ce notamment qui ok qu'il a
appelé la soirée du 13 novembre pour
leur dire venez me chercher venez me
chercher à Paris j'ai une panne de
voiture et qui apprennent en arrivant
sur place qu'il a concouru aux attentats
du 13 novembre cela ils sont en prison
ou ils ont fait de la détention
préventive ils en valent beaucoup à cela
meslave donc on sent que des fois il se
passe des choses dans le BOC certains
ont refusé de se présenter parce que ils
étaient peut-être trop bavard pendant
l'enquête et pendant l'audience il ne
voulait plus parler peut-être le silence
de l'un a provoqué le silence de l'autre
et puis certains
voulais pas charger son voisin on a
senti parfois des tensions entre par
exemple ça l'a Abdeslam principal accusé
et son voisin il se trouve que ils
étaient rangés par ordre alphabétique si
je peux dire dans le box donc il y avait
Abdeslam et abrini de copains d'enfance
mais il s'envole un peu est-ce qu'ils
vont balancer l'un sur l'autre et à un
moment donné on sait qu'on a failli
peut-être aller un peu plus loin dans la
parole de là dès que ça a été bloqué
parce que peut-être il y a une logique
d'omerta qui a fini quand même un peu
par prévaloir il ne voulait pas
s'accuser les uns les autres Rafael Kem
vous avez mis l'accent tout à l'heure
sur peut-être des carences qu'il y
aurait eu du côté de l'enquête et qui
peut-être servait davantage finalement
la défense c'est ce qui vous a intéressé
tout particulièrement évidemment c'est
peut-être plus l'enquête vous et les
carences susceptibles d'être perçus du
côté des enquêteurs français et belges
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure du des
inspecteurs belges bien sûr bien sûr
alors je voudrais répondre après avant
son osier aussi parce que c'est
intéressant les zones d'ombre ou les
carences
moi j'en ai vu énormément elles n'ont
pas été comblées par cette audience et
par exemple lorsque vous avez présenté
cette émission mais présenté comme
l'avocat diassinata en expliquant très
longuement qui était le frère de
yassinata où ça m'a Attard le
commanditaire des attentats nous le
savons je ne vous en fais absolument pas
le reproche mais je dis juste que
lorsqu'on pense à yassinata on pense
immédiatement à son frère ou à ses
cousin et finalement on ne sait pas quoi
dire sur lui alors on va tout de même
rappeler parce que les clients qu'il
était tout de même soupçonné avant ce
procès d'avoir détenu la clé une clé de
la plante bruxelloise ou ces réfugiés
c'est l'abdeslam après les attentats
c'est d'ailleurs également dans cette
plante qui ont été fabriquées les
ceintures explosives dont on s'est servi
à Paris et puis votre client est donc
été arrêté à Bruxelles en mars 2016 vous
voyez c'est très important que que vous
me disiez soupçonné de ces faits mais
c'est très intéressant parce que
voyez-vous cette histoire de clé c'est
une histoire qui a été abandonnée
pendant l'information judiciaire Yacine
Attar n'était pas accusé dans ce procès
d'avoir détenu cette clé mais finalement
il a été accusé deux choses multiples et
variées au cours de l'information
judiciaire au cours de l'enquête et
finalement au procès il ne reste plus
grand chose et on se rattache à des
éléments et par et par exemple on vient
dire et c'est ce que j'ai lu hier dans
la dans la motivation de la décision de
la Cour d'Assise que mon client a eu des
des relations téléphoniques intenses
avec son cousin Khalid El baraoui dont
je rappelle qu'il a organisé le 13
novembre avec son frère
Ibrahim et qu'il est mort aux attentats
de Bruxelles en mars 2016 et donc mon
client il est contact très intenses avec
cette personne là le 13 novembre dans
l'après-midi et nous avons expliqué me
semble-t-il la raison que ces contacts
expliquaient pour d'autres raisons qui
n'avaient rien à voir avec la
préparation des attentats mais
finalement la cour d'assise laisse dans
l'ombre parce que votre question porte
sur les zones d'ombre ce qu'il s'est
passé entre ces personnes là le 13
novembre et et on a rien pu démontrer et
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'une
décision de cour d'assis soit fondée sur
le fait que finalement on n'arrive pas
pas démontrer quelque chose et on attend
de la parole des accusés que eux
viennent prouver leur innocence et ça
c'est une forme d'inversion je vais être
un peu technique il faut le dire au
téléspectateurs d'inversion de la charge
de la preuve qui a un principe
fondamental qui découle de la
présomption d'innocence et qui existe
que ce soit l'accusation qui démontre
une culpabilité un mot juste un mot pour
rebondir sur ce que nous a dit Vincent
nouzi tout à l'heure et aussi un peu que
l'argent Schmidt sur cette question de
la parole des accusés moi finalement en
tant qu'avocat de la défense je vais
peut-être vous vous surprendre mais la
parole des accusés nommé terrestre pas
ou très peu et pourtant j'avais j'avais
les personnes autour de ces tables
savent l'accusé il y a sinatar qui a été
qualifiée de pipelette et qui n’arrêtait
pas de parler et dans ces derniers mots
il a surpris tout le monde parce qu'il a
dit je serais bref et il a été ceci
étant dit moi ce qui m'intéresse dans un
procès parce que c'est une accusation
qui accuse et qui veut obtenir des
condamnations ce qui même s'adresse
c'est la parole de l'accusation
c'est la parole du parquet qui vient de
dire pourquoi ils ont accusé un tel un
tel et sur la base de quoi et nous avons
dû attendre sur des questions aussi
fondamentales que celles par exemple de
savoir pourquoi des personnes étaient
jugées pour le 13 novembre à Paris et
pourquoi d'autres personnes étaient
jugées pour le 13 novembre à Bruxelles
nous avons dû attendre une fuite dans la
presse au milieu du procès sur France
Inter dans magistrat du parquet et le
réquisitoire du parc est général en juin
enfin en juin cette année pour
comprendre quelles étaient les
motivations du parquet sur la la
distinction entre les accusés de Paris
les accusés de Bruxelles donc moi s'il y
a s'il y a une partie dans ce procès qui
a été trop silencieuse c'est bien
l'accusation et moi j'attendais plus de
de d'explication de la part du parquet
au cours des débats
vous voulez réagir la moitié de là où
c'est ce qui vient d'être dit oui parce
que c'est en fait c'est très intéressant
parce que c'est le
c'est la limite entre l'exercice très
pénal d'un procès et l'exercice
historique qui est un mot qui a été très
galvaudé pendant ces audiences nous on
voulait comme journaliste venir
écrire l'histoire telle qu'elle s'était
déroulée alors c'est très délicat de
prendre la parole sur un plateau
télévision à côté de l'avocat qui
défendait sinataire mais on peut prendre
d'autres exemples sur ceux qui ont fait
et sans forcément citer tous leurs noms
mais ce qu'on appelait les convoyeurs de
salade d'Islam sur cette phase qui est
très identifiable et connue de tout le
monde qui est juste après le 13 novembre
donc le 14 novembre au matin quand il y
a le retour on va interroger les accusés
sur savoir s'il connaissait le fait des
attentats avaient été commis à Paris
pour constituer finalement l'association
centrale de malfaiteur terroriste et
pourquoi ils allaient le chercher est-ce
que c'était effectivement un problème de
voiture où est-ce que c'était autre
chose et effectivement ce grand procès
historique c'est
360 tomes de dossiers et ce million de
pages se réduit parfois des dialogues
assez ubuesques en demandant à l'accusé
ce qu'il faisait dans la voiture est-ce
qu'il écoutait la radio est-ce qu'il
avait vu des panneaux d'affichage et
l'accuser c'est Monsieur Amri en
l'occurrence sur ce volet là disant ben
non moi j'avais fumé du shit du roulais
j'écoutais de la musique j'écoute pas
les infos et on était vraiment pas sur
le champ pénal on était sur de la
connaissance et je trouve que
effectivement cette parole des accusés
on a essayé de la puiser de façon
extrême et qu'on n'a pas eu les réponses
de leur côté et qu'en revanche la
défense en pense qu'elle en pense mais
l'accusation a choisi de décrire
l'histoire elle a choisi dans un
réquisitoire très fleuve très tissé et
fleuve décrire l'histoire et de donner à
chacun un rôle qui correspondait avec
des éléments matériels très classiques
conduire une voiture aller chercher un
terroriste qui vous appelle au téléphone
pour le faire coller sur une
incrimination terroriste et ensuite la
cour d'assise effectivement à voter et
appliquer des peines
sur cet aspect donc on est à la
frontière entre la l'écriture d'une
histoire au sens commun du terme que
s'est-il passé et effectivement des
incriminations pénales et effectivement
dans des gens qui ne sont pas dans ils
n'ont pas de journaux intimes ils n'ont
pas des communications permanentes ils
n'ont des communications peut-être
beaucoup plus confuses que tout à chacun
ils sont parfois un peu ancrés dans une
forme de délinquance quand même on n'est
pas dans une histoire rigoureuse et du
coup cette lecture pénale elle a pu
manquer et la défense a fait un rôle
très éclairant là-dessus sur le fait
qu'effectivement on ne peut pas être sur
une impression brumeuse d'un trajet sur
l'autoroute A1 pour arriver à des
accusations pénales le verdict il est
tombé il y a quelques jours on va
commencer bien sûr par Sala Abdeslam
parce que c'est le seul membre survivant
de ce commando c'est le dixième homme du
commando
parisien réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité incompressible c'était la
cinquième fois je crois dans dans
l'histoire dans le judiciaire française
qui était prononcée cette peine elle est
prononcée aussi à l'encontre d'accuser
n'était pas dans le box des accusés
parce que présumé mort 5 d'entre eux en
tout cas
ce verdict concernant c'est un véritable
très c'est un verdict très très complet
très riche assez stratégique puisque
symboliquement ça considéré comme le
principal accusé prend l'appel la plus
lourde du code pénal
donc hier on voit bien qu'au-delà de son
cas personnel qui pouvait être discuté
plus avant concernant sa personnalité
son évolution concernant même son rôle
a-t-il renoncé ou pas à se faire sauter
les juges ont considéré il est considéré
qu'il n'avait jamais renoncé que c'était
sa ceinture qui avait été défectueuse et
donc ils ont écartés se renoncement donc
ils ont tout a été fait pour le charger
au maximum peut-être parce qu'aux yeux
de l'opinion publique il faut il fallait
qu'il porte un chapeau peut-être à mon
avis un peu large un peu large pour le
rôle qu'il a joué mais peu importe
l'ensemble du reste de décision
pareil extrêmement
équilibré au sens où ils ont suivi les
réquisitions du parquet très souvent
mais on les a menuisant un petit peu de
manière à bien faire comprendre à chacun
qu'on avait un peu écouté ce qu'ils
avaient dit est-ce que leur avocat avait
dit pendant l'audience c'est qu'on avait
individualisé les peines parce que c'est
pas un bloc et les peines vont de 1 an
de prison ferme à la perpétuité
incompressible c'est pour montrer la
variété des Sorges judiciaires qui ont
été tranchées par la Cour le 29 juin le
15 avril
échappé à personne et on a le sentiment
que le personnage se fissure
vous avez réussi à faire parler ça l'a
amené cela
n'a pas joué visiblement pour ce qui est
du verdict final malgré tout concernant
ce personnage précisément vous avez vu
une émulation du personnage et de son
comportement tout au long de ce procès
oui mais même avant quand étudiant le
dossier c'est un dossier qu'on a
travaillé avec ma concert Aurélie
cerceau on a démarré dès le mois de
janvier les questions qu'on avait à lui
poser on a senti un besoin de sa part de
parler une ambivalence à l'époque et
encore à cette audience des difficultés
à prendre la parole aussi après six
années d'incarcération
alors il l'avait pas prise non plus à
Bruxelles dans un procès précédent on
peut pas dire qu'il n'avait jamais parlé
en fait il a parlé une fois quand il a
été arrêté oui mais c'est pas toujours
c'est pas toujours
il a parlé une fois quand il a été
arrêté en mars 2016 elle parle et une
fois il a dit des
après durant l'audience et c'est après
cette première prise de parole en mars
2016 qui s'est enfermé dans le mutisme
donc nous on a abordé l'audience au mois
de septembre dernier on se demandant
est-ce que c'est la des slam va parler
ou pas est-ce qu'il va rester mythique
ou est-ce qu'il va s'exprimer et il
s'est exprimé alors au début de la façon
la plus provocante soit-elle il sortait
de ses six années d'isolement c'est des
années extrêmement contraignantes et
puis au fil des audiences on a senti
qu'il est aussi être davantage entre la
provocation et puis voir à certains
moments un peu dans les élans d'empathie
moi j'ai senti chez lui au moment de
certains témoignages de victimes une
empathie alors toujours maladroitement
exprimé mais je suis d'avis et vraiment
je l'assume que dans le box les accusés
ne restent pas insensibles aux
témoignages de victimes c'est vrai que
vraiment pour rester insensible
témoignage des victimes qu'on entendu
pendant 5 semaines faudrait être
sacrément psychopathe qu'aucun expert
psychiatre décelé dans le box donc on a
senti un besoin de la part de l'islam de
parler et puis ça tombait bien parce que
non représente des gens qui avaient
besoin de l'entendre qui avait besoin
d'entendre beaucoup de choses savoir
comment ça s'est passé et puis de
comprendre le comprendre pourquoi ce
garçon est dans le box aujourd'hui donc
ça n'a pas été simple puis c'est pas
facile de l'entendre c'est pas facile de
l'entendre parce que sa parole parfois
fait mal ça fait encore plus son mutisme
fait encore plus mal on lui a fait
comprendre avec Aurélie cerceau que on
était capable on était apte à prendre la
parole c'est plus simple pour nous parce
qu'on ne juge pas nous nous sommes pas
juges nous sommes partis civils nous
venons là pour comprendre il est présumé
innocent le but c'est la manifestation
de la vérité donc l'important de créer
des changes après on fait ce qu'on veut
de sa prise de parole alors on entendait
le verdict pour d'autres personnes clés
dans ce box des accusés Mohamed vous
avez évoqué son cas tout à l'heure mais
c'est vrai que surnommé l'homme au
chapeau parce qu'effectivement il y a eu
des des vidéos de lui dans l'aéroport de
Zaventem à l'occasion du double attentat
à Bruxelles ça c'est en mars 2016
c'était quelques mois après
et puis aussi attendre du verdict
concernant Sofiane Ayari
Osama à crayeb voilà trois personnages
sur lesquels on attendait de savoir quel
était de le verdict de ce procès au
métier Delahousse pour ces trois-là mais
ce sont des peines qui sont prononcées
de façon très très dure
ils n'ont des rôles beaucoup plus confus
finalement que celui de salade d'eslam
qu'on a fini par comprendre mais ces
gens là je les individualise pas
volontairement
c'est poser une question très forte sur
eux c'est de savoir est-ce qu'ils
étaient interchangeables parce que c'est
aussi l'une des grandes questions de ce
procès on n'a pas voulu juger le
terrorisme on a voulu juger des hommes
mais à certains moments une avocate de
la défense de façon extrêmement
brillante l'irlines la dit dans sa
plaidoirie et le parquet national enduit
terroriste a évoqué aussi cette notion
d'interchanbilité mais qui est
vertigineuse parce que les hommes que
vous évoquez
on pense qu'ils étaient des membres des
kamikazes potentiels alors évidemment
notamment sur sur Amsterdam mais on les
attentats de people qui n'a avec des
repères
dans une date qui était envisagée celle
du 13 novembre également et
effectivement eux ont des peines très
lourdes sur une scène unique de crime
qui est reconnue par la cour d'assises
parce que c'est aussi l'un des éléments
très importants de ce verdict qui au
niveau du droit pur pose question c'est
à dire que toutes les scènes de crimes
sont rassemblées Stade de France
terrasse Bataclan et on considère que
même si ça allait slam ne s'est pas
rendu en personne au Bataclan il est
complice et qu'il est en droit
responsable doit répondre voilà
absolument de ces endroits où il n'était
pas et c'est le cas aussi de tous ces
hommes de tous ceux
de je sais pas comment le qualifier de
cette espèce d'état-major du box des
accusés qui étaient des hommes sur
lesquels pesaient beaucoup de choses et
puis certains notamment quand même qui
ont décidé de se taire et donc ça a
renforcé cet aspect de de mystères et ça
renforce aussi je sais pas s'il est
temps de le dire maintenant mais une
impression sur le procès qui est fait
que ce procès n'a pas mis fin au
terrorisme ce procès a mis fin à la
structure qui était autour de V13 et on
a jugé des hommes on les a
individualisés on les a entendus mais
combien de SA macrayeb c'est la desclam
combien de divisions et c'est vrai que
cette question est restée très suspendue
à l'occasion notamment de choses qui ont
été contestées par la défense sur le
simple cadre pénal c'est l'avenue à la
barre d'experts notamment Hugo Micheron
qui fait des exposés extrêmement
intéressants intellectuellement mais qui
effectivement sorte totalement de la
boîte du cadre pénal yassinata a donc
lui été condamné à 8 ans
d'emprisonnement avec deux tiers de
période de sûreté alors je l'ai dit en
vous présentant c'est moins que ce qui
était reçu par le ministère public
je vais me demander si c'était pour vous
un peu une petite victoire non pas du
tout c'est un échec parce que lorsqu'on
présent on se présente devant une cour
d'assises en espérant à quitter un homme
dont on pense qu'il est enfermé à tort
depuis six années si on est condamné
c'est évidemment un un immense échec
voilà je vais réfléchir vous accompagne
ce qu'il s'est passé
lorsque je vous dis que sur yassinata on
a pas réussi à dire qu'elle aide il
avait apporté finalement ce pourquoi il
est Infiné condamné c'est le fait qu'il
ait le frère de Oussama tar le fait
qu'il est le cousin des frères al
baqaraoui et qu'il a été en contact à
certains moments avec eux et d'une
certaine manière ce que vient dire la
cour d'assise c'est que on ne peut pas
être en contact avec des gens qui sont
radicalisés dont on aurait dû penser
qu'ils allaient commettre des attentats
et c'est en ça qu'il y a un glissement
qui selon moi nous fait un petit peu
sortir de l'état de droit parce qu'on
vient criminaliser des liens on vient
criminaliser le fait de ne pas dénoncer
quelqu'un dont on aurait dû savoir qu'il
allait commettre des attentats comme si
les citoyens devaient se substituer au
service de renseignement et finalement
je suis peut-être un tout petit peu en
désaccord avec Mathieu Delahaye sur la
question des dépositions de certains
experts sociologues comme Bernard
Rougier qui a déposé à la barre ou un
maître cifaoui ou Gilles Kepel qui n'est
pas venu mais qui est dans le même champ
intellectuel qui parle de djihadisme
d'atmosphère d'écosystèmes islamiste
avec cette idée que finalement la la
présence de l'islam dans l'Islam un peu
trop revendicatif un peu trop salafiste
conduit nécessairement l'islam politique
nécessairement en théorie oui mais non
ce que disent ces auteurs c'est que s'il
y a un islam un peu trop présent dans
l'espace public et bien cela crée un
écosystème dans lequel peut naître du
terrorisme comme s'il y avait cette ce
glissement et d'ailleurs c'est apparu
dans une réquisition de Monsieur Nicolas
braconnet l'avocat général qui a cité
Bernard Rougier très clairement dans ses
réquisitions qui ensuite a dit que parmi
les signes de radicalisation il y avait
par exemple le fait de ne pas serrer la
main des femmes ou de ne pas écouter ou
de s'arrêter d'écouter de la musique
notamment et je trouve que ça c'est très
important parce que ce qu'on vient punir
c'est le fait d'avoir été en contact
avec des gens dont on aurait dû
constater que par exemple il ne serait
plus la main des femmes et dont on
aurait dû en déduire leur intention
terroriste alors ça fait réagir de ce
côté là bien sûr et ensuite on parlera
de la suite parce que d'autres procès
sont à venir je fais pas exactement la
même lecture pas précisément sur
yassinata mais ce que
s'ils sont venus et je pense notamment à
Hugo Micheron davantage dans le
témoignage j'étais très pertinent c'est
que oui
mais le message c'est que on ne peut pas
détacher complètement la situation vous
accuser de l'organisation qui sont
accusées d'avoir servi l'État islamique
c'est une organisation terroriste qui a
ses codes son histoire son
fonctionnement c'est prescriptions il y
a un mode de fonctionnement un mode
d'engagement un mode de formation un
mode un mode de renvoi vers l'Europe
d'envoi vers l'Europe pour la mission
évidemment c'est le travail de la
défense que je respecte complètement
mais cette façon de saucissonner
complètement de façon chirurgicale et
d'essayer de détacher complètement la
situation de l'accusé de l'organisation
est assez vaine car finalement les deux
sont liés évidemment que les deux sont
liées voilà pas spécialement pour
yassinata mais ça s'applique pour
l'ensemble des accusés bon il nous reste
très peu de temps je voulais parler
évidemment des procès à venir façon nous
y en Belgique le procès de Bruxelles le
double attentat métro et aéroport
bruxellois c'est tout de même 32 morts
plusieurs centaines de blessés également
sur place et puis bien sûr le procès de
Nice qui lui aussi est à venir qui se
tiendra très exactement au même
emplacement au même endroit dans la même
cour d'assise spéciale que celle où
s'est déroulée le procès du 13 novembre
2015 est-ce qu'on va assister à au même
type de procès à Bruxelles à Nice que
celui auquel on a assisté ici à Paris
alors il y a des points de ressemblance
puisque pour le procès de Nice ça va
être la même salle on va avoir une dans
le fond je pense que le procès V13 un
impact sur les procès qui suivent
notamment sur la place de la partie
civile on va on va avoir à nouveau 5
semaines probablement de témoignages de
participer donc le poids des participes
dans ces procès de terrorisme et
maintenant un acquis quelque part du
fait du nombre de victimes bien sûr mais
je pense que ça va bien au-delà de la de
la quantité c'est aussi une forme de
respect de volonté de résilience de
reconnaissance de l'état de victime qui
est un acquis de ce procès là et qui va
avoir un impact sur les autres sur le
procès le procès de 10 sera forcément
très différent puisque les victimes sont
pas les mêmes les accusés dans le box
sont beaucoup moins impliqués
directement dans les faits que ceux qui
étaient présents en revanche en revanche
à certaines accusés qui étaient dans le
box à l'occasion de se procès vont se
retrouver à nouveau dans le box cette
fois à Bruxelles c'est le cas l'automne
prochain
donc les deux principaux accusés qui
vont être transférés de la France vers
la Belgique pour assister à leur procès
concernant donc l'effet qui concerne les
préparatifs les attentats de Bruxelles
c'est-à-dire on considère que à partir
du 18 novembre
parlant du 18 novembre 2015 jusqu'au 22
mars ce sont ces félins qui vont être
jugés à Bruxelles pendant près d'un an
mais devant un jury populaire cette
fois-ci Mathieu Delahousse salut depuis
2015 concernant ces deux procès à venir
alors de ces deux à venir mais sur
d'autres parce que vous savez combien de
procès aux assises ont été jugés contre
les actes de terrorisme depuis 2015 il y
en a 55 et Nord ceux qui viennent il y a
les grands procès dont tout le monde à
l'esprit mais il y a l'affaire de
Magnanville de policiers tués à domicile
et à la faire Samuel Paty qui arrivera
un jour
au procès il y a l'histoire de cette
église de Nice qui a été attaqué et donc
toute une kyrielle de dossier avec des
parties civils qui sont présentes et
avec la même problématique des auteurs
morts là aussi la Bala pour parler de du
dossier de de Magnanville a été tué par
les par les forces de l'ordre et on
retrouve des kyrielles de complices de
de d'appui logistique etc et on sera
dans cette même problématique de faits
qui ont troublé l'ordre social de façon
absolue sur lequel il y a des réponses
qui sont attendues mais je pense que
Nice ce sera l'une des grandes
difficultés quand on regarde moi j'ai
écrit plusieurs articles dans l'Obs sur
Nice les charges qui pèsent sur les
accusés de Nice on va pas dire qu'elle
soit légère mais on peut dire de façon
indubitable avant même tout jugement
qu'elles sont éloignées des faits il y a
des hommes qui sont poursuivis pour
avoir fourni des armes qui n'ont pas
servi par exemple c'est le cas de l'un
des accusés comment juge-t-on ça comment
appartient une réponse face à cette soif
de justice que le procès V13 a concentré
je pense qu'il ne faut pas que cette
soif de justice se transforme en
vengeance et la question que je me pose
face à ces procès c'est est-ce que ces
procès sont une réponse et une
manifestation de l'État de droit face à
la barbarie où est-ce que d'une certaine
manière on peut aussi déceler une forme
de victoire du terrorisme je pense que
cette question est absolument capitale
parce que si on regarde ce qui s'est
passé au cours du procès du 13 novembre
cette question s'est posée est-ce que
les terroristes attaquent nos valeurs et
parmi nos valeurs il y a la justice
l'état droit sont en quoi nous croyons
tous ou est-ce qu'ils attaquent pour
d'autres raisons bien moi je pense que
si on laisse penser qu'il s'attaque à
nos valeurs et que nous on en oublie nos
valeurs et bien on a perdu et moi je
pense que sur le 13 novembre nous avons
perdu un peu de nos valeurs lorsqu'on
décide de condamner malgré des doutes
lorsqu'on décide de condamner alors
qu'on ne sait pas et lorsqu'on condamne
sur la base de raisonnement
impressionniste
vous aurez le mot de la fin vous serez à
nouveau présente dans cette salle
d'audience cette même salle d'audience
cette fois pour les attentats du 14
juillet
la similitude avec des 13 c'est qu'il y
a eu un nombre de morts considérables et
que les victimes attendent leur
maîtresse et que pour une victime d'un
attentat qui en atteint le plus grand
nombre l'objectif c'est de sortir de la
masse c'est d'être individualisé donc
ils attendent cette audience pour
déposer vous savez déposer c'est un
terme qui n'est pas anodin on remet un
peu de son fardeau il y a une forme de
catharsis même si ce n'est pas
l'objectif de la justice mais ces
process servent aussi à cela donc
effectivement nous terminons V13 nous
sommes déjà dans l'analyse de ce qui
s'est passé et puis hier j'ai déjà reçu
un coup de téléphone d'une victime de
Nice qui me dit est-ce que c'est
important témoigner quel est mon intérêt
comment puis-je le faire nous voilà déjà
transporté vers cette prochaine audience
ce procès de Nice c'est donc à l'auto
prochain il se tiendra on l'a dit dans
cette même salle d'audience avec une
visio qui sera évidemment
500 places à Nice avec 500 places de
prévu merci vraiment un grand merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à ce
débat dock aujourd'hui à l'issue de
verdict de ce fameux procès du 13
novembre 2015 Vincent Douzi et on attend
avec impatience ce que sera votre film
qui a été tourné durant ce même procès
vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag des
Badoc bien sûr sur Twitter mais si la
seule massali aussi qui m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission et puis surtout
surtout rester avec nous puisque va
suivre dans quelques instants les trois
derniers volets de votre série exclusive
pour notre chaîne V13 à très bientôt
[Musique]